something that keeps coming up in our
interview today is like people's skills
and just working with people and it
sounds like you've really worked on
yourself you've worked on reading I know
you've said that in Prior interviews
that some books on leadership are more
important than actually film books and I
find that very interesting because most
people would do the opposite yeah I
think we're in the business of with
people this is a team sport I was safe
with football like footballs at teams
for even with Tom Brady he needs these
receivers he needs a college spread
offense he needs whatever he needs to
make this happen so with film you are
dealing with people I don't care if
you're the most brilliant savant in the
world at some point you're going to have
to deal with people so for that reason
anyone in the in the industry especially
producers especially writers because you
have to be able to convey your thoughts
and ideas and not just you know hold it
in here and only doing on paper you have
to actually talk sometime just working
on your people skills in a way that is
practical reading going to conferences
hearing things listening to audios
things like that I read leadership books
for far more than I read entertainment
books or film books or screenwriting
books and the reason is I can of course
become a better writer or a better
producer or a better filmmaker by
learning the X's and O's just like in
film I'm sorry just like in football but
how am I going to get this team to
operate right or how am I going to get
myself to operate within that team
correctly that's a people skill so if
you build that the rest of it can be
worked on it can be be forged in
practice but you come into a situation
you have not practiced and you have not
built that people still you're gonna
disqualify yourself before you even get
to show your art and get to show how
brilliant you are and all the stories
inside of you so many people
I don't think failure usually comes from
people that have don't have the ability
but it usually comes because they didn't
have the emotional IQ to handle the
pressure the conflict the anything that
can impede success is usually a personal
issue it's not because you didn't know
not knowing something I mean we're an
informational age you can google
anything so with all this information
our fingertips and
we're still dropping off like in such a
bad way they cheat on their wife it's a
horrible like it's like Expo if you're
on every channel you've done such and
such or you treated your employees bad
and they're all blogging about it the
New York Post now has an op-ed from your
CEO or whatever that just quit whatever
happens that's not because they didn't
have the ability in their business and
your enterprise so if they're filing
because of a personal problem so if we
work on yourself you can be better in
any industry especially ours because it
truly is a team effort and as creatives
we we want to flow and have the freedom
to create but it's like to have freedom
if you don't have the money because
money also very same but to our freedom
the only way is for someone to open the
door for you and not close those doors
in your face that's how we get freedom
that's why Christopher Nolan can make
whatever he wants because he was able to
put himself in a place not just to be
brilliant cuz there's so many brilliant
people there Christopher Nolan's age
that had the same schooling but they're
not Christopher Nolan he did something
to where teams and people at opportune
times open doors for him where he could
freely create and I don't think that
only comes with brilliance because I
know so many brilliant people that are
like not doing anything with her life or
even stuck in some little office
somewhere wishing that they could create
so yeah for the doors to open you either
need a boatload of money from mommy and
daddy or you need to have people skills
in some capacity so working on that it's
very important well is there an example
that you saw of someone and you don't
really have to name their name but where
you just saw how they handled something
and it was so brilliant how they
diffused the situations we know film
sets it's a long day or even if it's
just an email people they get sensitive
and they get mad and maybe they take
things the wrong way or they're not I
know we talked about people not knowing
the word no or they can't handle the
word know you know which it's
interesting when you say that to someone
and you see how they react but did you
ever see someone where they just they
handled it brilliantly and you were like
wow I want to be like that yeah for me
the first example was a negative one on
film sets watching producer specifically
be horrible to people and they lead and
they motivate it through fear and
paychecks that's the motivation I'm
paying you work
or you're scared of me work or you're
Intimidator wear whatever it is so it's
like the producers come in sterilized
all of a sudden like okay or the ad is
just like cursing you out instead of
just yelling hey I need you guys to do
XYZ for this day to go forward whatever
it is so I saw the negative part of it
but as a child I saw the positive and
then I also had the opportunity and the
blessing to know Chad Morton my
executive producer on the last film I
did he is the money guy but yet he is
the nicest person and also we had a
situation in another project where
someone cheated us like they were
submitting work artwork that was stolen
it was totally not that they were
submitting these things that were not
theirs and we found out about it and the
way he handled it was so amazing to me I
was ready to rip this girl's head off
like how could she she kind of ruined
everything cuz I was like if these got
out we could've been sued and all this
crazy stuff and he had a conversation
with her and I was I was with him and
she fought him vehemently and said
negative things to him and just was
horrible and he said I'm sorry you feel
that way the only thing I'm here for you
to tell you you won't be working with us
anymore and I hope you don't do this
with anyone else I wish you all the best
and he didn't even respond to the
negativity and we went about our
business and I was like that's it like
you're not gonna soar and it was like he
said something to me I can't remember
the exact words but he didn't want to
let that negativity go any further than
what it already did we experienced
something that was very real we had to
get in front of it and we had to deal
with it we dealt with it we got rid of
her
we got a river for artwork we wasted
money she wasn't even that money back we
had already paid her and everything but
if he continued to dwell on it and
complain about it and continue to try
and get money from her that he he wasn't
getting his money then now we're still
in a negative space two or three weeks
from now a month from now well we
could've just won about our business and
solve more problems found more artwork
or whatever it was so I think that for
something that I learned from Chad just
kind of like let things be a little bit
more easy and rub off like roll off your
shoulders in a place of grace and in a
place of like selfishness like I don't
want to take this negativity with me
today I hear what you're doing I'm not
even to respond to a negative I'm gonna
correct the problem just logically and
then walk away and then on the flip side
of that watching film producers 80s
cetera rule in a fearful or just I'm
paying you do your work type way I'd
already as a child for my pastor my dad
different people in my life saw
leadership without that without the
negativity servant leadership so that's
how I my leadership it fits more into
the servant leadership
mindset where I'll just give you a quick
little baby story my pastor like he
would be the guy this is the pastor
right like he's sweeping what we came
into the church he's sweeping up things
and this other gentleman walked up was
like pastor no no let me do that please
don't ever do that so he took it from
him and he walked away and I was a
little inquisitive girl that just saw
this moment I was like why did you want
to sweep and he's like it's not that
it's just it had to be done and it
wasn't even a big deal to him he's like
he had to be done I had some time and it
was like oh and I think just being a kid
seeing that or like my dad who was my
coach and soccer like he just always led
with not put downs he led with
positivity and then also he led with the
idea that let me make you better like
let me make you better so I'm gonna be
really hard on you but I'm coming
because I care about you I'm gonna make
you better so when you go to the next
level you're better like let me do that
for you and he would say that to the
kids like hey I'm only talking to you
because you're messing up but I can help
you cuz I've already done it so that's
this stance I have with anyone that
works with me for me and any with like
any capacity I want to make everybody in
the room better and vice versa they're
gonna make me better too they're gonna
grow me especially they have a bad
attitude you're gonna work so hard to
get to that person in a way that kind of
diffuses that you're gonna be better now
I can on the next one I mean attitudes
don't mean anything to me someone that
has a negative kind of take like kind of
countenance about them countenance
excuse me I'm like oh this is easy I'm
ready for that like I've experienced
like the most like dramatic and negative
people on set since like I'll we're fine
so it they it's the don't panic I saw
such negative motivations on set
negative you know put down or stay in
your place or whatever and I saw the
outcome of that which is a great movie
but also the people were not happy so it
could have been even greater and I
really believe that when you are working
with the team if you make everyone feel
comfortable but also
high expectation like you're cared for
but do you have a high expectation I
found that that's the best fit for me to
motivate so yeah Rachel expects this
from you and you feel like you can only
can do this but I see that in you I'm
not just going to like do this I'm gonna
say let me help you get there and I
learned that for my father it's like let
me help you get better let me help you
but I'm not going to take oh I can't do
it or this is what I have to offer no
I'm not taking that but I care so much
about you I'm gonna stay up tonight and
talk to you on the phone and we're gonna
go through all that you just worked on
yesterday and I'm not gonna sleep and
I'm fine with that because I want to
help you get better
so that idea I think was fashioned in
front of me as a child and I apply it
but the real issue is in film that's the
usual cases the adverse and we've
learned though like me going onto set if
I hadn't had any other idea that it
could actually work in a big way without
that then I'm thinking oh when I get
there I have to leave with the iron fist
or they won't do their jobs now I do
believe that high expectations are so
necessary for people to grow I do but I
earn fist isn't because you'll never be
able to motivate someone past self
motivation because you're only trying to
match what is inside of them so
whatever's inside of them can go further
than you can push them to if you can
unlock it instead of pounding it so it's
like unlock that person and they'll work
harder and I learned that actually from
my hands in producing events not film
and I and that's another thing for
producers it's great that you produce
film but have you had any form of
leadership in your life other than film
and I think for me that that that gave
me a balance so the leadership was in
sports being the captain on the team or
something but also producing events
because okay I'm an event like the US
Open or whatever and these people the
the client is saying these people are
lazy they're not smiling they're not
this or not that and then finding out
instead of just firing a person are they
being utilized in a place that fits
their personality that person's not a
greeter that person is an extrovert and
you're telling them you're saying they
have a bad attitude because you set them
at an information desk and they're the
person that should be working in over
there helping out with tech or whatever
it is so finding places so knowing that
part of it it's not the same in film you
can say oh let's try you
manager today but you can realize that
that person wants to do this if your own
a film set you want to do it in some
capacity maybe you want to be a director
and they're just a PA but they want to
be here so why we have an opportunity to
do the best kind of leadership because
in other corporations you got to deal
with I don't know how to be here I don't
care about coca-cola
or whatever the thing is I care but
everyone in film they care about film
they like movies so use that what is it
about you and this is what I do when I
first bring someone onto my team
what's your dreams in this business what
are your goals and even just hearing
that kind of gives you an idea so when
you see that person underperforming and
something that they want for life you
have to know it's not because they're
lazy it's because their motivations are
off or they don't feel empowered enough
or they're not able to verbalize
something that's bothering them so don't
panic when you see a negative thing and
start cursing everybody out or thinking
that's the only way to handle it in a
war type mentality like day of you have
to handle it quickly but then you can
always circle back because even if I
have to be like guys this is happening
move that's different then guys will
have moved
something's happening move and I haven't
connected to you the day before I didn't
connect with you after the film you have
to establish care first to then give
advice power push motivation because if
I haven't showed them that they're not
gonna respond to me with anything but
fear like we talked about motivating in
fear or how I got to get paid so let me
just go ahead so I'm limiting their
input in their initiative in a situation
that I needed I need them to be excited
to be here I need them to want to do it
so why not help them do it as leaders we
sometimes act like all these people are
lazy oh they're negative well change it
what about the culture of your set or
what about the culture of how you hire
them tells them that you don't care so
that yeah they're bringing that to the
to the set I don't care
they do care they're in film they want
to be in film so they care so I had that
understanding don't panic when you see a
negative response and take ownership in
that be a servant leader take ownership
that well maybe there's something I can
do on my end and if there isn't but some
time is totally the person I'm going to
confront it in a way that lets them know
it's not just the action that's gonna
cause us a problem you're hurting the
team you're hurting yourself and guess
what next time
I might not be you to bring you on and
if I don't bring you on and I care about
you what's gonna happen for the guy that
doesn't they're not gonna be bother with
you so let me help you what's the
problem let me help you through it
and then we can we can achieve something
better rather than just like oh these
idiots or whatever the place you could
come from that I see happen one sense
all the time
you